there is no curse in elvish and tissue
or the tongues of men for this treachery
last week I officially launched my new
website that guy with the glasses com2
advertise it I created a trail filled
with zooming text bright flashes and
some fast speed editing not a few days
later I posted a detailed list of what
movies I was going to review next first
a short tribute to Animaniacs and then
the wizard a 1980s film that was
sponsored by Nintendo right now I'm
about halfway through editing and so far
no complaints but then less than 24
hours later take a look at what the
Angry Video Game Nerd posted on his site
gee it's a trailer filled with zooming
text bright flashes and some fast beat
editing oh and it also turns out that
the guy who reviews nothing but video
games is also reviewing a movie which
movie you may ask well how about the
fucking wizard
you dirty stuck-up sadistic shit-eating
cocksuckin but fucking penis smelling
crotch grabbing bulb licking semen
drinking dog raping nazi loving child
touching cow humping perverted spineless
heartless mindless dickless testicle
Chokin urine gargle and jerk off in
horse face sheep fondling toilet kissing
subcenter feces puking dildo Shelby's
not spitting crap gathering big-nosed
monkeys slapping bastards growing be
shedding third knocking sack busting
sploosh tasting beer blowing head
swallowing bitch snatching hand dropping
donkey caressing mucus viewing anal
plugging pool grabbing uncircumcised
sewer sipping whoremongering pit
swimming midget munching douche bags
home biting carnivorous mail-order
practice
at all you just could let me get to it
first could you
you just had to steal my thunder so it
seems that the Angry Video Game Nerd has
officially become the irate gamer to my
incredible genius
all right that was too far but still the
evidence fans I posted my list of
reviews on April 21st and the angry
video game nerd posted his review on
April 22nd that means he had to write
the material set up the shots shoot the
video transfer it edited and posted on
website all in less than 24 hours what
kind of sick jealous rage pushes a man
to such limits well let me tell you
something I will not be intimidated in
light of this rivalry I've decided to
push my review to next week as opposed
to two weeks later and I am going to
avoid your review like the plague cuz I
don't want any of your videogame
nerdiness tampering with my views so I
leave you angry video game nerd with
this statement I'm the Nostalgia Critic
I remember it so you hear me you don't
have to by the way what you say about
Lucas wasn't that cute hilarious oh my
god I had so much fun writing jokes
about I hate you